agenda and i would like to fix it to
start with my deep appreciation to
clear and in some sense i really want to
say and single out michael
for this we have a tremendous set of
papers and uh michael's
coming here and starting to work with i
enough i can say ross as well
and developing the papers meant that i
think our committee is really starting
to climb the maturity curve which is
where
i am very keen that the committee goes
so certainly nuclear but also
particularly you michael thank you very
much
for the input
to what i think are a quality set of
papers for this meeting
it poses a problem for us which is time
i'm told that i have to have this
meeting finished by 11. and
when you have good papers there's always
the perverse actually you want to have
better debate
and after all we are a committee of risk
where the thing about risk and assurance
is that you want to be able to debate
them
so i am going to have to try and rein
myself and first and foremost and then
potentially you folk
um with an attempt to try and do it this
way
i'd like to buy hapas9 um to have got
through to
item 16 so item 16 if you refer to your
agendas
is a paper with a report essentially
on our finance system
implementation update the the the second
last
and the last items in public
uh i'd like to be there bahabas9 if i
could um we also have
a substantial uh item and relationship
or items in relationship to public
excluded as well and we need to have the
hour and a half that i would have in the
remainder for that
um to be able to finish by
11 o'clock so that's my intention if we
can do it
that way can i just note please uh in
all good formality i've gone past that
we can remind you that we are being live
streamed as is appropriate and um
if anybody is joining us by live stream
i would welcome you but particularly
marcus we haven't met before um but look
thank you for um finding the time the
effort to come in from where i
understand you are elsewhere
around the country it's great to have
you here as well
um welcome thanks for that my pleasure
and anybody else from the i think we've
got the rest of the committee here so
it's good alan weldon you're here
we do have a couple of um apologies um
uh bex is unable
to be here today as is alex i have no
other
apologies so from the chair i'd like to
move that those
apologies are sustained could i have a
second to please thank you not
staying already aren't i rangy sorry
thank you rangi all those in favor
please say aye those against it's
carried
i haven't been informed of anybody
wishing to be heard in public forum
um the interest register um
through the good work of malawika has
been updated which is great mainly
because i was a
bit slow and tardy is there any matters
on the agenda
today that people need to raise their
interests over
there'd be none we'll continue okay can
we please move to
um the minutes of our last meeting which
actually was sort of was an odd set of
meeting meetings you remember
essentially it was the 14th of december
but we were also trying to adopt our
annual report and you will recall that
the meeting was adjourned
till 8 30 on the 15th and then because
of the contingencies of working through
that we adjourned that and we met
at 2 30 in the afternoon to conclude
the hard yards of both michael and his
team and the auditors
so we have three sets of minutes the
main meeting on the 14th
and two short meetings on the 15th
unless there's any objection i propose
that we
treat all three papers and one hit
are there any matters of accuracy or
correction that people
would like to raise at this point from
those meetings
i have reviewed the minutes they look
like the they look like the meeting that
i was at so that's helpful
so look i'd like to move from the chair
that we received these as a correct
record of the meeting can i have a
second to please
thank you darren all those in favor
please say aye
bruce were you actually at the second
two meetings
yes i was yes yes i was i zoomed in
yep certainly was the last one yeah fair
point no but i definitely was
uh all those in favor please say aye
those against
it's kerry thank you right
so if we could um move then please to
the report on the
long long-term plan that would be great
thank you
and brienne
good morning how are you
thank you chad i'll take the report as
read
um i think the most important thing is
at this point that a long-term plan is
still on schedule
um their resourcing remains tight
um but as the report states probably the
order part of the process is the most
significant
um i might just pass to
the gm finance insurance if he wishes to
say any more about audit
just just to let the committee know
their audit is in their
final stages so we're expecting
something by the end of the week
in relation to the audit opinion at this
point
audit is still on a non-qualified
approach so that is good from our
perspective but we're still waiting to
hear back from them today
brilliant thank you for that short and
sweet well i like it the other questions
from the
committee
right if i just get a couple of very
quick ones in here let's just go to the
table
on page 21. this becomes critical i
appreciate that uh um uh
it's it's uh it's i hear the point about
resourcing we'll get to the risks um
pretty quickly
we can just check so firstly we are
going to have
um uh let's just remind ourselves
consultation document is what michael
was talking about in terms of an audit
opinion
and is obviously for staff and for you
as councillors the first point of
completion so you can go
you can go to consultation you are
looking to adopt that
on the 30th of march correct
29th 29th okay
absolutely sorry so the table isn't yeah
i get it so anyway
we we we are aiming and it appears that
you are on schedule for that michael yes
brilliant
including the fact that the audit
opinion has to go obviously
um uh consultation goes through that and
we'll just come back to that because
there is a request for a motion as far
as that's concerned
um within subject to auditors you've got
a dates out of them yet
uh audits hopefully going to have their
draft finished by the end of today
for us to have a review oh sorry i mean
in terms of the in terms of the ltp
it just needs to be confirmed yeah no we
haven't got the actual dates that
they're going to be in yet
for that component right okay that's a
worry uh can i be honest let's um let's
check that we need that right that's not
necessarily a problem for you it may
well be audited as uncertain at the
stage um but i given
we're heading to a 30 june adoption date
you can't go past 30 june
so i'd be very keen michael if we could
make certain that with the auditors we
have even our best estimates at this
stage otherwise it's difficult to manage
please
right um the consultations there is a
there is a
a reasonable part of the resolution is
that we note the plan for the management
consultation
in case of covert resurgence is anything
there that you'd like to tell us
about that please and you've asked us
for a motion
only that i thought from a risk
management point of view that obviously
this is something that will be on
councillor's minds the plan lays out the
plan for level two level three or level
four depending on which
circumstance may arise during the time
of consultation either before or during
and it notes that we will continue the
consultation
irrespective of which level that we're
in and lays out how we will achieve that
brilliant darren you've got a question
more
a comment here just that this was a
process that was interrupted by covert
last year
um and we were doing that on the hoof
this year we're going into it with
with a strategy and i'm relatively
comfortable around that plus
we won't be the only council in that
position if it if it happens so
um obviously it's one of the the key
things that could interrupt the whole
process but
i'm comfortable with what the report's
recommending thanks darren appreciate
that
um i just wanted to check this is
consistent with national
national approaches i assume it does
like a similar thing we we
the only thing that worried me was are
there any compliance
obligations in terms of consultation if
we move to the higher
levels yes this takes into account
those requirements that's why i'm
recommending staff
be re-allocated to make phone calls to
people
because that is the largest issue um it
arose in conversations around annual
plan
last year um so we sought legal advice
at that point
so that's why the plans laid out as it
is brilliant thank you very much
right if we just moved into the tables
please 2026
and page 26 and 27 again
um very well set out thank you in terms
of
the risks if i've got my color coding
right blue is the medium and it's the
highest
and looking i think as you quite rightly
indicate that generally comes round to
resourcing i presume in terms of the
consultation document we are
broadly broadly so to speak there the
critical question would be the ongoing
work around consultation assessment of
of the um the feedback through
consultation
and in the finalization of the ltp so
that ladder but still remains
stretch yes we're expecting probably a
large number of submissions
particularly around high profile
projects like the museum but also the
proposals to the change to the rating
process
yes there's no doubt there's very
limited team numbers in the strategy and
policy teams so
processing all of those submissions
and booking hearings is going to be a
challenge nevertheless we've
we've road tested it we've got um
technology lined up we're working
closely with the governance team to try
and make that really smooth
transition there is very little time
between the
submissions closing and the hearings and
then deliberation
and the other aspect is if the
counsellors hear from the public
um feedback that leads them to wish to
change significant parts of the
long-term plan then obviously the
constraints within the finance team
around the ability to change the budgets
as the second element
of concern because you'll see there's a
very tight turnaround between
deliberation
and audit arriving on the 28th of may
so that's the second
and very significant pinch point thank
you
that's that's very clear so all we can
do is we can just acknowledge that we
have we can only at this stage
acknowledge
the risk um you have got plans in place
along with michael
uh and it's a case of monitoring that
risk and how it comes out
i guess at the stage correct that's good
thank you that's very clear can
can i do a final sweep any other
questions people would like to raise
about this
it's a great piece of work but we we
will be going down to the wire
right can we move to the recommendations
please uh
firstly we receive secondly that we note
the reschedule which we've just gone
through
and thirdly has as has been asked we
note the
um quite sound including the legal
compliance aspects of having to alter
out the nature of our consultation
should uh the unwanted events of moving
up levels
actually occur somebody prepared to move
this motion please
thank you darren do i have a second
thank you rangi
i'll put all three motions all those in
favor please say aye
those against carrie thank you thank you
thank you very much for your report can
we please go to the quarterly report
it's jamie or michael or both thank you
jamie in your hands sir yep um firstly
it would
like to table a draft financial summary
hopefully it's been
distributed around
uh do we need to get approved or put on
the table oh we can do that through the
resolution
i'm happy for it to be tabled if you
could talk us through it please that
would be great
cool um firstly i'll start off with just
why we're delaying the quality report
for another month
due to some staff resourcing we've had
to put on to other projects like getting
the annual report across the line
um we've had to delay um
just because we haven't had the
resources to fulfill
what we'd normally do in the process um
we're also getting familiar with the
system as well
and we don't want to put up something
that we're not confident
in ourselves that said
um so what you've got in front of you is
a draft what we've
got in the system at the moment from a
top level
currently showing a deficit of 2.3
million
against the forecast of 6.7
just the key points out of it um
from operational side um the big one
that stands out is
the other expenses is quite a lot lower
than what we
were anticipating um there is still a
few costs still to go into this area and
accruals as well
so we do believe that will come a lot
closer to the forecast
at the end the other big thing to
step out for is on this second page is
just with the capital
area um so at the moment the numbers
show we're just
under 9 million for the first two
quarters of the year
there is again a number of accruals that
need to go into this area
to bring it up a wee bit but it
still will be looking to be below
forecast
and i'll just open it for questions
there
thank you jamie i appreciate the fact
that you've tabled the paper is
indicative of
of some of the pressure that currently
is being faced in the finance function
so i am grateful that rather than just
the blank paper so to speak that we've
had we actually have
that so so well done uh what i'm hearing
you say if i've got this correctly is
the primary issue is
is probably partly systems writer which
is you haven't got all the accruals
in at this stage therefore the the full
picture isn't able to be
shown correct great yeah okay i
appreciate the honesty that's what we
need
i'll open it up uh for discussion we do
we do have a discussion about a separate
discussion later on about the system
itself
so if we could avoid that but talk about
the results there's anything people
would like to raise on this place
we also by the way have a separate
discussion further down the track around
the capex as well but it may be that
there are
maybe there are questions here that
people have as well
yes ross uh firstly in terms of the
accruals
is that work actually done it's set to
be complete this week
yeah so it's a matter of timing and
we've got you a week too early is what
you're saying yes
yeah and just secondly i presume on the
last page we say investments is
i presume it needs increase rather than
decrease
i know it actually is a decrease so we
hold
30 million in advance to the holding
group
so as an investment on our box um so
they're looking to repay that
at the end of this month and as well as
consequence we'll also repay our
debt as well so from a net perspective
there'll be no impact
yes but yes okay that's fine you get
that
ross was anything else you had dressed
no that's fine i appreciate that it's a
reasonably
quick look at the stage um i just wonder
if we could have a very
i think i guess i've got my head got it
right we just have a quick look at the
last paragraph of the actual substantive
paper sent through by
uh jamie and by michael recognizing
uh in good faith they're trying to be up
front with us with their at but look
let's let's be comfortable that the
actual
approach they're taking is there so
performance policy and partnership
get the right they're there and that's
your group you will get um
financials for the april it's sorry at
your april 2021 meeting yes
so in effect the week that you needed if
we were a week later
that would have given rise to this
report being uh
strengthened you will get to the um
performance policy and partnership in
april correct yes good
and um with march coming reasonably
quickly on its
heels in may the following month yep so
essentially progressively catching up
good that's what we needed because june
is of course balance date so there we go
okay any other questions just by comment
chair uh they were actually due
at our february meeting but at that
point we were already alerted to
the delays so yeah yeah yeah no that's
appreciate that darren and look
obviously very convenient he keeps a
close eye there's a few questions i've
got when we get to the the tech one one
so we'll worry about the system when we
get there
jamie thank you for that um could i have
uh somebody move
please the motions first will be
received and certainly we know the time
of writing
we have received a high level summary
thank you rangi
do i have a second to thank you nobi any
discussion on the motion i should put
that actually before i put it
there isn't i'll put the motions please
all those in favor please say
aye those against it's carried
thank you for that jamie appreciate that
the draft risk management framework
peter welcome we haven't met i'm sorry
to get a chance to shake your hand
before the the meeting but
uh it's great to have you on board this
again as uh if i can just
give the committee the benefit of my
views is tremendous that we again
are starting to climb that maturity
curve and one of the first places we go
is by having
a policy there i say it and this is
great to see you going so peter i'm in
your hands if you give us a
nutshell of your paper i'll then open it
for discussion
thank you firstly morning mr chair
councillors your worship i'll take the
report as being read
i'd just like to highlight a couple of
areas firstly
what is risk and and this instant the
definition of risk is the effect of
uncertainty
on achieving an objective so clear
so a clear understanding of the
council's objectives is the first key
step in managing risks
and these objectives will come from our
long-term plan
you may have noted in the draft policy
that the
source of risk table on page nine
is blank there is a requirement to
develop the council's risk appetite and
to achieve this a workshop will be
conducted with council
prior to the june risk and insurance
committee meeting
we will work through that table and
complete the sources of risk table
so we can develop our risk appetite as a
council
open the question thank you appreciate
that right
folk open it up for questions uh from
the committee
yes frankie um on
last last wednesday we were in wanaka
some of us were
for a three waters workshop now
coming away from that workshop uh all i
could see was risk
and we had council has two options
it's faced with one is staying in one is
opting out
and to for council to choose
whatever option um moving forward
i see it as risk choosing which option
presents
the less risk there are no benefits
because
you expect the three waters to be
provided
now looking at the risk
of staying in i asked a
reasonably simple question what our
30-year
long term infrastructure
asset renewal plan would that stay in
place
and they said no so it would make you
wonder
what's going to happen are they are they
just looking in the short term
and we could be effectively cast aside
you don't know
so so that's that's a risk of staying in
but then
then opting out you have the risks of um
the compliance levels which we don't
know and they could be
just unachievable on the budget you know
on the finance we have so
um that decision would it feed through
this framework
would it wouldn't come through yeah i
like your question because it's quite a
good one it's a very it's what i would
call a strategic risk
undoubtedly it's big so peter your views
how the
this framework enables that sort of risk
to be integrated yes
yeah how um we will run through the
um the process of going through a
workshop
on the risks and we'll create the scores
we'll look at what the mitigation is and
what controls there may be
for both options i.e staying in or
opting out of it and council would then
be able to make an informed decision on
which way to go so if i can just get for
my clarification of the fat circuit beta
so our workshop in june
would be amongst other things
identifying what i might well what i've
just described and
rangi subscribe but i've shown it to
being strategic risk we will have a
chance
as a committee to define what are the
big risks that we believe are affecting
the city
yes cracker that's what we need to do so
rangi that's
my view the answer we're going to have
to deal with that when we have our
workshop
in june because that would be very
helpful
in that yeah yeah the other the other
sort of more
more minor comment i have there was a
mention of
dashboard type systems uh
instead of states that um
starting simple with spreadsheet based
approach which i really appreciate
because
i'm not a fan of dashboards i mean
there's quite a few cars driving around
with the oil light on
and it doesn't help anybody i mean you
basically with a risk you actually
identify it you look at the mitigation
and then you modern you monitor it and
i see dashboards as being a way that you
look at it and it doesn't it doesn't
get into you the same way as someone
writing down
in the [ __ ] you know so you know
um that's i'm quite happy where we are
and not even go near the dashboard i
assume that's the technical word you're
using there uh
rangi if i can it comes from
infrastructure
it comes from a destruction it's a brown
water phone
um thank you for that uh and and so
there's some feedback about the nature
of the
the sort of feedback that that rangy at
least would like to
other members have views around the
policy please
um one of the things peter that i was
just trying to look for and and i think
i get it progressively and i go back to
i go back to what uh what are the big
risks of one of my favorite word at the
moment is existential the three waters
one is almost
existential for any of any territorial
local authority right at the moment
can i can i um just check or ask you
just to recheck the policy
because when i looked at um when i
looked at uh
uh page 38 of the poll oh sorry page 38
of our agenda
i don't know what that is in terms of
the actual it's page four of the actual
policy
and i looked at two and the risk
registers i get it
this this policy is very much driven
from the
bottom up which strikes me as
absolutely traditional it makes a lot of
sense
we are working with staff to defy risks
at a functional level
we're expecting departmental managers to
own those risks
it moves into the elt they they
in their own right form a risk group on
the lines of defense
but then obviously there's also us
there's a risk insurance committee
and to some extent we want to also
ensure the strategic or the top-down
risk
is covered which goes back to rangi's
point i didn't get that flavor
in the risk framework until i got to the
appendix
when you started to describe some of the
some of the risks so if i could
make a plea please if you could just
re-look at the policy
which to me otherwise is is pretty good
that we get
the sense of what is the role of the
risk insurance committee and
particularly
as it's as its guardianship for um
for those big strategic risks
i do have one other point that i'd like
to make which is actually
the place of internal audit
and i would like us in the fullness of
time i'd rather get this going on the
risk side
but in the fullness of time i'd like us
to develop an assurance
policy which really fits under the
framework it's our name risk and
assurance
we need to have a sense of actually how
we gain assurance
that the risks themselves are being
managed and internal
obviously is a key function as far as
that's concerned
brilliant right if we just check my
notes anybody else got any other
comments while i
do that are we we comfortable guys
we are yeah knobby yeah just
just as a reinforcement what rangy said
i guess um
i was also the three waters as well and
um
that's probably the biggest decision
we're going to make yeah in the next 10
years is not the cost of fresh water
but it's whether we stay in or whether
we opt out
and when i think about the information
we'll need to make that we can't just do
in a single workshop
we're going to need some real expertise
to tell us about what the cost is to
stay out
um and the issue about if we stay in
is a moving feast i guess
ringy and i and others have been to uh
several meetings with the dia
and and the commonality through those
meetings is
they don't know what staying in is
actually all about
we keep tell we keep getting told that
it's economy of scale which is a cost
factor
and yet in the same breath they say that
that doesn't actually apply to otago
southland because there's no economy at
scale we're too widely spread
and then networks are too widely spread
so the cost of the community will
probably be the same won't matter
whether we're in or out the cost will be
the same
the issue for me is how do you compare
the second issue is
what will have ranging tasks on it what
will our future investment be
an infrastructure if work in a coalition
which the coalition will probably the
original probably south island given
queenstown dunedin have high needs
and so does christchurch i think
investment in the south and one
and avocado will be very low for a long
period of time where if we stay alone it
may not be
um so bobby thank you for that they're
coming up
can i say that this really reflects the
importance of us with this workshop in
june and some i mean we are we are
starting from behind the start line
yeah uh in that we we don't have our
risk register up now so this is a
maturity issue for us to get to get
to get the speed up um because if this
was
you know if we already had a top risk
register this would be something that we
would be talking at least
quarterly bearing in mind that the risk
committee doesn't run
the work that you need to do to be able
to respond appropriately to
to the three waters it's something which
i presume
elsewhere you've got governance
arrangements in place or will have
governance arrangements in place
to actually deal with the with the
matter is that i think that's correct
clear that's reasonable
i think at some stage may not be there
yet you're still you're only just being
to wanaka you're still finding out what
the story is
but that will be the case we as we as a
risk committee should have a concern
have we acknowledged the risk we have
actually what are our controls in place
to make certain that we
we make decisions in a timely way with
the best information
right i sense
a combination of uh
we've probably got some acceptance
around the draft policy as it
stands with some comments for you to
consider peter but
i think also we are reflecting to the
meeting that actually
uh while it's been used as example not
unnaturally three waters is a
is a significant challenge which is
immediate on the horizon not on the
horizons with us now
can i move to the uh resolutions please
which is that we
firstly received the report with thanks
peter we
endorse the risk management framework
policy and process for introduction
across the council
in brackets with suitable amendment
close brackets
as suggested at the committee that is in
the committee notes the risk appetite
table will be worked through
at the next risk and assurance meeting
can i just change that also please to
the committee notes the risk appetite or
the strategic risks and risk appetite
table will be worked with through the
through
at the with the councillors and mayor
prior to the next
uh risk and insurance sorry then was one
other question there i presume that also
includes the independence
please i think otherwise it wouldn't be
the best workshop you need to have your
independent members there as well
yes right so sorry malavika i've got
this all over the place
um i would like to suggest that the
third one says the committee notes that
the strategic risks
were identified sorry the committee
notes that the identification
of the strategic risks
and
definition of of our risk appetite
and drop the word table
we'll be worked through with uh
counsellors
and met counsellors common mayor and
independent members
of the risk insurance committee prior to
the next meeting
i mean nothing worse but having people
watch me talk from
public so you're doing well
yep prior to the next yeah
yes please with uh with um so endorse
the draft risk management framework
policy and processes uh including
suggested amendments
uh made at the meeting for introduction
across the council
i think that's almost my wedding um i i
will
i propose that i will put the motion do
i have a second please
thank you nobby um i think we'll treat
them all as one all those in favor
please say
aye i alright those against it's kerry
thank you
right moving along insurance
michael thank you
so this report is on the insurance that
we've taken for the year
um we're out of sequence in relation to
this reporting
normally we'd come to you prior to the
insurance
or being being adopted
we insurance is from the november period
so we've adjusted that in the sequence
which is later in the agenda around the
annual work program
i'll take the report as read and we're
just looking for
getting assurance from the
council that this cover is seen as
adequate from their
perspective thanks michael
um so look from my take i'd tell you
it's not actually inappropriate it's
just that actually in some ways
the real thing is to choose what cover
you want to take going forward when you
balance it up against the risks and the
risks
risks you are prepared to take on board
or carry as a council
uh here we've got a report on what we
have so it's valuable on its own right
do i have questions from the committee
at all about the insurances we
we carry oh sorry russ
one bruce the cover looks very
comprehensive the only question
i'd have is around the business
interruption and you consider 24 month
indemnity
appropriate or have you looked at a
shorter
indemnity period and therefore reduced
premium
given how long it might take to get up
and running we haven't
at this stage but i can take that on
advisement you wish us to look at that
yes yes sir tim is the
insurance cover should i be at this
meeting
i'm comfortable uh so tim that we are
reporting on the cover we have in place
um i'm comfortable that you it's quite a
proof you'll still be in the room
yes nobby michael um
on page 56 which is the second page and
it talks about
professional indemnity is that the
coverages for elected members
no that's the coverage for um council
itself
um in its operations
so where does our our elected member
coverage fit i was scrolling through
that i couldn't see it
uh that's part of the local government
act
side of it so it's separate to that from
that perspective
okay thank you
the other questions are running so just
just following on from
nobby's question so the lga
it they have to the the insurance has to
respect the lga and what it says
the act you know so if that covers the
indemnity for the members then
it would then not not opt out of it or
have any clause that would
and actually go against what the access
that is correct
okay are there any other questions
people like to raise
i just um uh note and i'm sure this is
really more as much uh
michael for the next meeting
but of course one of the one of the
things that we'll have to weigh in the
balance
as we move to the next meeting where we
would consider what is the what is the
cover that is appropriate to purchase
if i've got this right in terms of the
key policies and the big numbers
given the range of years that michael's
helpfully shown us
i think i've seen at least a 30 increase
in premium
over that time and i would suspect that
this year that it would be no
less a change in terms of the increases
and in fact even we might have to accept
higher excess to be able to even retain
some level of cover um i'm not
the full expert but i i just am
reflecting on the trends
and i was reflecting yesterday watching
some of the news coming out of new south
wales
over the 100 year flood
previous advice has been that the
underwriters in
london see these clearly they naturally
do
and that it also means that actually
uh um that it could well have impacts
across the
the certainly our market uh as well
so interesting to see where it goes the
other thing which actually i think we
need to think about and it's good that
we're going through the ltp is
the tendency now for the underwriters to
want specific information about specific
authorities
so that they can assess their risk area
the quality of our asset management
plans and being able to tell the story
becomes increasingly more critical when
it comes to meal but that's for our next
meeting
okay can i move to the motion please
which is that we receive the report
um and that we confirm that it's
appropriate at the moment there's
nothing that i've heard that suggests
they're allergic to what we have
can i just ask a question about the
second
recommendation i'm not actually clear on
i guess process or what that's intended
to mean a question i guess of michael is
there a
subsequent resolution to be considered
by the committee or council as to what
the terms of the cover will be and what
the premiums will be
or is this effectively that decision
it's for me it's a regrettable point
we're at
which is that this is in retrospect
and it's reviewing what cover we have in
place
had we done it the other way around
which we will do going forward
is review as you say the terms
and conditions prior to then that would
be
at the time you would have that
recommendation
we'll get to when we get to our program
lindsay we you will see that we have
slotted in a
uh a separate item prior to the newer
round on one november
where we will consider our arrangements
going
forward so i think um the this is as
much to reflect an accountability for
the cover that we do have
um and and i think the second leg of the
resolution
is is really just a chance for
affirmation that we are comfortable with
where we are at at the moment
doesn't mean to say that we this isn't
anything about the cover that we may or
may not want to buy
going forward okay so so could i suggest
on the strength of that
chair that the second resolution says
something to that effect
that the committee confirms that the
uh terms and premiums for
the council's insurance cover set out an
appendix one to the report
b because then it nails what it is yep
that we are saying
is appropriate yes otherwise it's a bit
loose
can we get um look so
so i'm very comfortable we get down
there so could you just help melodica
get the words right for that please
lindsay
yes please yes assume we're doing it
live we should see that as we look to
pass the motion well mel obviously does
it as any other question people like to
raise
just the handwritten thing
critical point is that we're going to
use snobby and just just to go back to
your shy rates i i still don't
understand why
we've got a paper here that covers all
the um
insurance that we've got but it excludes
what we've got under
under the arrangement with risk pool
which is our insurance for
elected members and if it's not to be
here then
at what stage do we get to i guess have
some discussion about that
given that the we've had a pending court
case that
discussed the issue of third-party
coverage and
i'd like to like to think that somewhere
along the lines whatever arrangement
we've got in place now
has closed any loopholes that leaves us
exposed again
i think that we have some unclarity
there so i'd like i'd like to invite
michael to come back to us
after the meeting nobby just to clarify
the nature of the cover
yep and public liability which must
exist
including for councillors so let's let's
just get the clarity of the detail on
that
uh as we um as we go forward
thank you for that lindsey appreciate
the the um the the detail that makes uh
that makes good sense
so we obviously receive reports
certainly the committee approves um
uh well actually i think we have ended
sorry lindsey being i didn't realize
that was here we have entered the
contract
so it's not it's not as if we can it's
actually more a case than we were to
seek amendment so i think we're actually
we're approving contracts entered to
provide material damage and business
interruption insurance cover
on terms and conditions and premiums set
out in appendix one to the report
we've entered them it's not a case of uh
entering
um i'll get that changed yes so for the
sake of for the sake of the meeting
in progress could i could i um please uh
um uh somebody were they prepared to
move this motion thank you darren could
i have a second
thank you navi uh and we'll pass us on
the basis recognizing that michael will
come back to all of us in relationship
to your christian lobby with the details
i'll put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
those against it's kerry thank you very
much
can i move to the treasury report
please jamie thank you
uh it was darren thank you
thank you jamie all right um i'll take
the reporters read um i'll just
highlight a couple of things that
happened in the last the second quarter
of the year
so we have drawn down three and a half
million um from our gfa
to advanced funds to the holding group
um
towards the city center investments
and also we've renewed our bnz core
loan facility um for another two years
and that's
facilities for 10 million is there any
questions
right thank you so we've all been
through this i
know from even some past uh
uh workshops with you folk um the
concept of our debt our our grace did
our investments in our
net position um and uh jamie i think
it's
important to look at uh the page 65.
there are two key diagrams there one is
one is the red line which is a debt
ceiling that we have set ourselves um
the pink line is
where we anticipated being in our last
long-term plan
and obviously the bar graph is the
actual net
debt that we hold
um and i think the explanation
underneath it is important
as well not actually meeting your budget
isn't necessary
or rather being under your budget isn't
always necessarily where you want to be
mostly our debt is about providing is
about
enabling the creation and provision of
services
not about trying to be in a particular
position so
i think we just need to reflect on that
um that the reason we're in that
position is because of the food capital
projects and cash surpluses
and we've already heard something about
actually the capex program and how far
we are behind
radio so that's that and then secondly
an important part for this is treasury
policy compliance statement which
reflects what's in our advisor's
comments further on
so can i raise uh open sorry for any
questions please
people like to raise new snobby um yeah
following on from the three waters issue
that we discussed just a few minutes ago
this graph's really important um
i guess the initial reaction from most
councils when you target southern region
was to say well if you're taking over
our three water assets which is a huge
chunk of our business
why would we invest in the next three
years before you do that well in fact
the reverse is actually the benefit got
confirmation
um last week from dia that um
when they transfer the assets in three
years time they will take with
the debt so for us the way forward
potentially is to make sure that we do
our
capital projects and don't delay them to
create the debt that needs to go because
the debt will disappear when the assets
disappear
and then you get the benefit for the
community not the reverse yeah
so that's quite an important graph to
show that we have some capacity to get
our
infrastructure up to up a certain level
before it goes across to three wars
like to reflect that i was most
interested in i'll be in the pink line
because that's actually where we were
planning to be if we were if we
had at the capacity to deliver on our
capex
which does include donatus things like
three orders renewal and what have you
so
yes i think we're all agreeing that we
need to keep well i think sorry the
sector is agreeing they need to keep up
its three waters approach even though
reform is occurring yeah we've got some
variations within the within the sector
yes some councils have held a skelter on
this and they're investing hand out of
this queenstown lake district
but there are others that have gone well
beyond the pink line and they've now got
problems
yes yeah okay there any other
comments now jamie i i would i'm
probably behalf of the committee but
probably myself want to ask the dumb
question
can we go to the compliance stuff please
and can you explain to me the
percentages
because it says we're compliant um and i
was trying to understand how the
percentages fit within the policy
limits okay um so
yeah normally i'll get um miles
right his numbers he knows the in and
out so it might pay just get him to put
up a paper
next time around okay to explain it
rather than me
get it wrong here okay appreciate that
michael are you able to help us many
chance
um only so far is to
understand those percentages um
i would suggest you to look at
trying to get the page yeah it's a great
diagram uh page 74
yes that shows the
the red line show the limits that we
need to operate in
the combination you should see
all of the i think it's a green line the
top line
separating the gray shows we should stay
within the two red lines
pretty much throughout that whole period
we get very close in some of those
periods in relation to our lines
which we need to work through about when
we take our next
rollover of debt etc so we're
monitoring that quite closely at the
moment in relation to staying within
good news is we're at the bottom of our
limits not at the upper of elements but
yeah um but i would agree with my
staff around getting in the expert to
actually give us a
report on that so i'm just wanting to
reflect to the committee this is one of
the critical things that we as a
committee need to
keep our eye on is actually are we
within our treasury limits
and actually the nature of the position
we take in the market in terms of
fixed versus flooding and how to
secure either the the risk position we
want to take is
is tied up in the living between the two
red lines
and while i still don't quite get the
percentages that exist inside the
diagram
sorry inside the graph this diagram is
actually reasonably important that we're
saying that there will be a minimum that
we will have
fixed and i must confess i was i was
thinking it might have ended
a line rather than the green line but
we'll take that on advice
that actually we are compliant and our
advisor says that we are but i think
michael i'm reflecting from the relative
sentiment i'm picking up from the
meeting that would be good if you and
jamie could follow through please on
this key compliance area for us
thank you right again if i could uh
move us please to the um
the motions um i think we probably do
need to change this
uh um uh so first we received the report
malavika
could we could we could we go uh on the
advice
uh of our right bank or our treasury
advisors
we note that there are no breaches of
the policy
and i won't have it in the motion but
we'll recognize that you folk will come
back so that we've got greater
clarification in our
collective mindsets to to the policies
how they stand
and how we interpret this better going
forward
thank you amalavika so i'll put the
motion uh that we receive and that we
on the basis of the advice we move this
do i have a second to please
thank you navi all those in favor please
say aye
those against it's carrie thank you
right moving along how are we going for
time too bad well done guys so it's good
to see the energy we'll get there
can we please uh look at the sensitive
expenditure report and jamie you're
still on the hot seat thank you
um again um common theme these are the
sensitive expenditures that we've
managed to get out of the system so far
um again there will be some more
to come through as we process over this
next week but we'll bring that in
with the next report with the as long as
with the next quarter as well
that's going to move the two
recommendations to you cool um can i
just
suggest one thing darren though soon i'm
into changing motions can i
can i suggest that you would like to
change
number two to note the expenditure is
reasonable
the reason i say that the reason we have
the sensitive expenditure here is
actually
we should be taking this as a sense
check there i say at the front page test
are we comfortable
that this is at a right level or what
i'm using as the word reasonable so i'd
like to suggest with your agreement
there happy with that
we change it to note the expenditure as
reasonable
sunni uh do i have a segment for that
please so darren's moved
thank you knobby seconds is there any
discussion actually on the expenditure
i sense people's appetite is to for me
to put the motion
all those all those in favor please say
aye
those against all right
i think from down there somewhere marcus
carried thank you
appreciate that right risk insurance
program
michael
so council before you have put forward
what is a proposed
risk risk and assurance work program for
the balance of the year
so highlighting which reports will be
brought forward
draw your attention probably to the
policy one that
we'll still need to come back with a
list of all the policies that we need to
bring through
um there's quite a number due this year
for renewal
so there will be a quite a list for us
to go through
um but just wanted to highlight that
that is an outstanding task to be done
is to work through that list
the other item i'll draw to your
attention was i was hoping to get the
procurement policy to this meeting
you'll see it's been deferred until the
14th of june meeting on on this timing
so
hopefully that'll be ready for that that
meeting
i'll take the program as read and open
to any
questions thank you michael um this is
actually oh sorry ross
reflectors this is a strong piece of
work by michael and his team to
upgrade our approach it does look
similar to the previous work plan we've
had but there's some significant
qualitative changes to it which i am um
obviously
encouraged by um and obviously had some
discussion with michael over it so
it's starting to put again our work in
the right place ross you've got some
questions
health and safety would appear to be
admitted or dropped off
thank you yes i would expect this
committee to have health and safety in
front of it um dare i say it almost
centre so
if we can include that please anything
else from folk in terms of the program
um i just had one question uh uh ross
sorry michael um if i've got it correct
um we're recommending to the council
that they adopt the annual report in
december that was last year i don't
presume we want to be december this year
no correct that one will be subject
change i'll hopefully be able to bring
that back to the 29th of
good september i think shift i think
that's reasonably important for us to
recognize we're going to try and do it
okay that's good good to have it in
place
um just to recognize everybody that
there are some key things that once
we've identified our key risks
at our june meeting we'll be wanting to
pick up on
some regular what would be called deep
dive
or discussions with the gm's over the
risks they own and how is it going
and that's tied up in that that second
uh banded part of the report on page 80
which is
group risk discussion with gm's that'll
be really important
as we start to running start deal some
of the questions you've raised over
things like
three waters right could we move to the
rec
that's right okay so we've got a we've
got
more changes to uh number two which i
think is going to say that the work
program
uh with the addition of a
quarterly health and safety report
be noted
oh and the egypt yeah end and yeah all
the other
adjustments which i think this was in
our scope to actually
approve it actually it's our program
we're saying it's good to go
okay so it is that we receive secondly
that uh that was the inclusion of the
health and safety report in a real
timely annual report
the work program and our last change be
the word
to from noted to approved could i move
that motion please
thank you ross could have a secondary
thank you rangi all those
in favor please say aye
it's carried thank you right there is a
very minor item from me which is number
15
which is a review of performance and
effectiveness of the
risk insurance committee this is a
little matter that's dead in my heart
which is that at the next by the next
meeting
i will hopefully have got to you know
don't laugh
[Laughter]
i will have asked you to undertake a
survey
i'm conscious at all good council
committees
if not counsel itself and it's all part
of working
on working together as well will
self-assess their performance
and i've got some advice from ross on an
appropriate way for us as a risk and
assurance committee to review
to review our performance and i think we
should
go through that process um so that we
can
buy june which of course is the end of
the financial year have some sense about
the
the comfort uh within amongst amongst
members
and there i say at senior staff about
the work of the committee and secondly
um well what i think will be an
improving management of our risks
so just literally putting that as a
heads up that we'll get that going
the fact that it's a verbal update you
might say mr chair was it meant to be
more than just the verbal update
anyway we're there and we are there at 9
30 in fact
do folk need three minutes if they need
a comfort stop or can we crack on
crack on okay here we go um so
uh thank you you've helped me get more
or less on time
to really uh um a couple of very key
papers
so uh michael i think it's you with the
um
the finance system implementation update
thank you
yes good morning chair you council is
your worship
before you have a real report about the
position and
of our current financial system and
how the implementation is progressing i
think
the key focus that i'll draw your
attention to within this report is just
the challenges
that it's giving for the financial team
with a resourcing depletion at the
moment
which we are trying to rectify as fast
as possible
but also the impact that that's having
on our services
as we speak we we still as
a council remain committed to the
financial system as it as as our
core financial processes going forward
and we are seeing some positive progress
over the last few months and
i think our key stats are all pointing
in the right direction from that
perspective
we've turned a real corner over i would
say since about december
in relation to the system i'll take the
report as
read and be open to any questions in
relation to it
as you consider the report members can i
just
point you to put to page 84. you may
have well have questions by the way
prior to page 84.
um but before we finish this item i
would like to just have a focus on the
key remaining tasks marketpreps it's a
warning to you
can i open this up for members of the
committee for questions firstly
for michael
yes darren thank you gee i guess michael
around around tracking
we've identified that there were um
challenges in
getting the best from the system and
then we had resourcing challenges
so you put steps in place to
to cover that off are we still tracking
well to
achieve those resets
uh the stats we use to measure
um how we're progressing are all
pointing in the right direction
i still remain under significant
pressure within the finance team it is
it's proving very difficult to recruit
the required resource
we have been out uh three times to the
market for a couple of roles
but we continue we're continuing to go
out
um the positive side to that is is our
stats are still holding and improving
even with the resource we have but i
think we've heard in earlier agenda
agenda items what that's resulting in
from that perspective
it's putting pressure and timing in
other areas so
can you can you just uh michael give us
an indication what are those stats by
the way
um sounds good stats point in the right
direction what are the stats that might
help
in the committee yeah so the the core
stats we're
monitoring are our turnover of our
purchase orders so
uh you know right down at the low level
in relation to
what i'm monitoring but also
our payment terms and meeting our
payment terms with our suppliers
we had had some issues getting those
through and
when the system first went in it was
only a small teething
time frame but was pain felt by our
suppliers as well
we have got on top of that from that
perspective we believe
and processing those according to the
time frames we're getting our payments
out we've got our
invoices down to processing the current
month's
invoices we were one or two months
behind in relation to those
so that's a key step for me from that
perspective making sure our purchasing
process is working
thank you for that that's a very good
open honest question answer thank you
for that michael if i can just defund
you for that and it reflects
clearly the stress this is tech 1 was
effectively
it if i understand it correctly um but
our implementation has been
stretched um it's almost a perfect storm
if i understand it correctly with both
the ltp the annual report and resourcing
issues
affecting it so can we go to the key
remaining tasks then please because um
i asked well michael has kept me
in the loop and i appreciate that
michael about where this is that
um and uh in the good government sid but
tell me the plan
tell me the plan because i'm very keen
to know that we can get to the end of
this
but actually it needs to be a plan that
we also as a committee
fully support so look i
i just want to reflect you propose to
have this
completed if i've read this correctly
oh sorry the project closes down by by
30 april essentially that means that you
must be comfortable that it that is in
play
you are going to do a post
implementation review which is actually
a really good thing to do by 30 june
and the critical thing as i understand
it you're saying here
is that while technically
the numbers are right we need to make
certain culturally
our staff use it properly hence the need
for a refresher
if not new training um uh communications
uh clearly you've mentioned the critical
word creditors or in other words our
suppliers
and you're keeping them in the loop as
far as that's concerned i think as a
council we should be concerned about
that from a reputational perspective
and there are four module timelines
which are critical to completing the
tech one
introduction um and you've got some
dates around that that's a good man
is there anything we can do to support
you mate
apart from the fact that i'm no techo so
i can't help you there i'll call out if
there's any resources we're always
looking
um but apart from that just keep
keep us on our toes and keep us to our
timelines we'll be appreciated as well
the pressure will help us to
see this through and get it complete not
certain i like putting staff under
pressure
i would rather we had a soft landing on
this one michael
i don't sense at this point there is
an immediate solution is there any sort
of reporting support that we could
provide you
provide for you during the course of
this time probably us keeping out of the
fire would make it even better
chair the one uh the one thing that this
the committee and
uh council as a whole has been very
supportive of is not putting the
pressure on in relation to
the reporting side of it which is a key
strain
um if that that support remains as we go
through
and just be aware that we are
still heading towards our june time june
timeline so
that's our critical focus but the
support that we've had from
council today has been amazing and i
would also say from our executive team
from our reporting as well
so we're very mindful that we are not
getting the information out but we are
also working towards
their at speed and as as a full team
effort so
we appreciate the support we are getting
laps i think
the hoses to ask the one question you
are comfortable despite
the challenges of tech one that we you
are comfortable that we have still got
suitable financial management control
uh yes at this point yes
are there any other questions from the
committee on this surprise does not and
just following
confident you'll have enough support
post end of april when the consultants
your key consultants disappear
um replay we have a plan in place around
the recruitment
with the consultants um it's kind of a
live plan
in relation to we're still working
through getting those uh
consultants to support us post april uh
i've just come from
uh last week working with my
counterparts right across the country to
see what resources are available
and it's fair to say this is felt right
throughout
new zealand in relation to the pressure
in this site
it's on the flip side they're also very
supportive
the one thing that will help us will be
the
opening up of the trans tasman bubble
the reason for that is the product we
have
is predominantly serviced out of
australia
that's where a lot of the technical
resources are that we will be able to
tap into
so that'll be something we'll as soon as
that's open we'll be looking at that as
a possibility as well
okay so look i i um i think uh i hear
the
the message that we um i'm glad have
been supportive and
still are incredibly uh michael and i
think we need to get that that
leave keep that policy on um i'll keep
letting you get on with us as it
goes look i just invite you if there are
any matters that you need to raise for
the benefit of the committee
please do so with me and with claire
as we as we work through this um
so that it gets there if there's no
other questions
i would like us to move to the uh the
recommendations please which is firstly
that we received the report
and secondly it's that we note the
challenges um to the organization
of the new ways of working with this
finance
system i'm happy to move that do i have
a second please
thank you rangi is any discussion on the
motion
all those in favor please say i
those against it's carried thank you
michael
you know i just want to support uh staff
and this thank you for being so
crystal clear with us over the
challenges you have been for a good
period of time now and you've continued
that and we've now got another good bit
of
clarity from aaron and tess which is we
could move please to the project
management office status report
welcome folks morning
we all have the appendix it's a colorful
one
love a diagram test you've got a long
way already with the committee when
you've come to me with a diagram that's
great
good that's good to hear it's um it's
difficult to present so much information
and try and make it as concise as
possible
so the this report provides a summary of
the projects that have been
um identified within the project
management office um the purpose of the
report is to identify those
projects that are tracking to green
which is okay amber which means that
we're watching them and
red is a project that um we're
escalating and we're working through
scenarios
ways to resolve the issues
in terms of the report would you like me
to go through each of the projects or
focus on specific ones
um well look i would like your view
please
tess before i open up to the members
what is it that you would like to draw
our attention to
look i suggest the reds if you yeah the
reds make sense um and there's going to
be a common theme running through this
which isn't dissimilar to michael in
terms of resourcing
um so in terms of the streetscapes
project
so that's the stage one streetscapes
upgrade that's happening to facilitate
the priority projects in the city
we do have scheduling concerns on that
one
where there are multiple fronts in terms
of what we've got to work through
integrating with the priority projects
making sure those projects can carry on
while we undertake the streetscapes and
we've also got to do
some three-water renewals in those
streets as well because we don't want to
be coming back in in the next 10 years
and ripping up the work that we've
already done
so from a scheduling perspective it is
quite complicated
financially we're having to deliver a
lot in a short time frame
so that always creates issues in terms
of how the market is going to respond so
we'll be asking a lot from contractors
so from a cost perspective there are
some concerns around how we're going to
be able to achieve it
um the scope when we're we're running
quickly with this project
um so just ensuring that we stay true to
the
purpose of the master plan is something
that we're obviously working through
closely but we don't want to lose sight
of what the scope is in the master plan
and look resourcing is going to be very
demanding on this project with a lot of
other work that's happening around the
district
in the civil's infrastructure space so
we um
we have a plan in place but we are quite
concerned from a resourcing point of
view
and then we've got a number of
dependencies on this project too which
i've just alluded to in terms of those
other priority projects and working with
three waters as well
um stakeholders is obviously critical on
this project
you know we've got um we've got the
community the retailers that we've got
to work with so there's a very high
level of stakeholder engagement on this
project
which is all leading us to a point where
it's um it's a critical project in terms
of just some of the challenges that
we're working through
thank you just uh practice just finish
off and before i'm not because i'm sure
there'll be questions from the news
sorry um so in terms of this smag which
is the next project that we've
highlighted as being a critical project
so that's the southern museum and art
gallery
um from a scheduled perspective it's
going to be a big project to get
moving we're obviously working through
the long term
plan so the project until we go through
consultation and we're just waiting to
to hear back on that from a scope
perspective there's going to be a lot of
competing interests on that project
so ensuring that the budget that we've
got matches
the people's expectations in terms of
the scope is going to be quite
critical um dependencies obviously you
know it's an important project for the
community so we've highlighted that um
as
read and again with stakeholders you
know there's a there's going to be a
myriad of stakeholders involved in this
project so
if it does come to light then it's going
to be reasonably complicated from that
perspective
and then the last project that we've
highlighted um as a red project
is the water tower the water tower has
proved quite challenging in terms of the
extent of the structural strengthening
to a category one heritage listed
building we've had to go through
a structural peer review which is just
about complete
but it it has proposed some challenges
which have had some financial
implications
again the scope with a category one
heritage building is quite complicated
in terms of what you can and can't do
resourcing it's going to be a demanding
project in terms of the type of work
that needs to be completed and finding
the right contractor
and could be complicated and then from a
quality perspective just making sure
what we do
provide when the limitations of a
heritage building
ticks people's boxes when the project is
finished
thank you tess that is uh that's very
helpful
and and insightful you and it's anything
you want to add to that or are you
i think the only thing that i'd add is
that we we have
challenged ourselves quite quite toughly
with how we've scored
um these and there is a lot of red um
there was certainly something that was
discussed
at our elt when we brought this through
i guess what i wanted to note is that in
terms of setting up a project management
office we identified
that as going to be our preferred way
forward
um back at the end of november um we
had eight weeks was the schedule we gave
ourselves to get that project management
office
up and running um which we stuck to
at the end of that eight weeks which was
the beginning of february
we ran this process across the projects
and
there was a lot more red on the
scorecard at that time
which means this is actually an improved
picture from what we did have
at that time so we are tracking in the
right direction but we definitely want
to be
very clear that this is a difficult
tight
program with a lot of moving pieces and
a lot of resource requirements
so we're going to have to keep a very
tight hold on it
well thank you you're inside i sense
there's probably two or three sort of
key areas to discuss here one is clearly
which you've just if i started what i
see
systems at the start the existence now
of a project management office the the
core discipline of actually how do we
deliver
our projects full stop there's the
projects themselves which tess has given
us
at least my guidance to focus on the
reds you may have questions on the
others
and actually also importantly a couple
of common
themes that are running through the
projects which are actually on the right
hand side of the
uh the diagram which is some of the
systemic issues you're facing which
you've
indicated as internal resourcing and
probably the contractor market and its
capacity
so that's very helpful i opened up for
members to raise questions if they have
any
there are none amazing
oh i can't let that go right it was a
challenge for me navi there must be a
question here mate
it must be um i guess one of the issues
through your chair is
will be the consultation process an
awful lot of work gone into this
and forward planning both from aaron's
perspective and from michael's
perspective around how we
manage these projects going forward
including um financials and uh ability
to deliver
but if we've gone too far down this
track and i don't think we have but if
we have
and i heard some time frames before the
scene consultation finishes in
and then about a month later we have to
get it to audit
um our ability to change where we're at
at the moment
is just about zero and one of the
one of the issues for me i guess around
that is why are we consulting if we
don't have any ability to change
um and the big issue in the big elephant
room of course is the new museum or the
strengths and museum or swag whatever
you want to call it
that's pushed out in our long-term plan
and i'm not sure there'll be a community
acceptance of that so i suspect the
feedback system will get the next month
or so
will overwhelm us on that and some staff
have alluded to that
um that's the take i have and so i'm not
sure that
process-wise we've actually got this
right i think it seems to me in some
ways that we'll listen to what the
community's got to say but then we'll
say
for a whole rough reason we can't
deliver what you want
so this is not just a what you want in
the last on the next month
the community have signaled way back in
the august last year what they wanted by
way of project prioritization
so i guess we're going to have a bit of
a dilemma when we get to that i guess
erin you can make a comment yeah i'll
just make the comment um
i won't talk to the challenges of
putting together the long-term plan but
i guess i just wanted to
talk to running a project management
office across
a long term plan period um and how we
adapt that process
i think the position that we would like
to get get to is that from a maturity
perspective we would always be
expecting to run our projects across
more than one long-term plan period
and that doesn't mean that things don't
change as we go through a long-term plan
process
and we can't adapt to that we
essentially just
we put in place a plan at a point in
time we continue to work to that
if something changes through the
long-term plan process then
we come back we make the adjustments
that we need to make and we continue to
move forward
that's not unusual really for any
process
as a council starts to mature through
these programs because
projects are long lead time items and we
will find that if we actually want to
deliver on these long lead time programs
we need to be starting them
ahead of a long-term plan process
thank you yes rangi i think
this report and the
chart here is actually very helpful
leading into the long-term plan
discussions because it
it clearly identifies what we've got to
do
first and it's no different than looking
after your own house i mean
why would you go buy a new lounge suite
when you've got a hole in the roof and
and the wind's blowing through i mean
it's just crazy um
and that's that's what this committee is
here for and hopefully
these priorities the key things that
councils should be doing
to make this you know the city uh
livable place as far as
we've got the cityscape you've got the
seed streets stock bank
and those critical three water renewals
have to take priority over the next
projects
there's that that's a no-brainer and
that needs to be this information needs
to feed into when we discuss it
later on this year thanks frankie
uh sir i think darren might have been
first leaving you listen thanks chad
look i just wanted to make uh
a comment about what can and can't be
changed picking up on on what counselor
client was saying is it is
very hard in fact almost impossible to
change
what you're consulting on at this stage
not what the ultimate decision is
that's not to say that once we've
finished the consultation that the time
frame that we'll have to come up with
the decision isn't going to be
compact and challenging itself but what
we're going to go out and consult on is
what we have no room to change at this
point
thanks darren leslie thanks mr chair
it's a very minor point but on page 87
can someone just remind me of why
there's a reference to the scottish hall
and the resources description
[Music]
sorry that's on as part of the appendix
on
those pages page 87 yeah
yes yeah first page
oh it is too i wonder what i was
thinking
there isn't there is i'm sorry there is
no reason why that should be there
so i don't know why i wrote the scottish
perhaps it's a autocorrect it's a bit
like streetscape or something
yeah actually i do know why i wrote it
um when we were looking at the cab
refurb
we were talking about the scottish hall
as being somewhere where we're going to
temporarily relocate staff
um so that obviously i never i i failed
to delete that piece
thank you thank you apologies that's all
i just
wondered if there was some significance
well there was a very successful
catholic uh gathering there good
i'm patrick as well great
wonderful test move to 88 and i think it
probably also reflects the point you
made aaron which
is actually uh the the multiple
period or year type nature of these
projects and you'll need to
to be front loading the development and
effect that's what it comes down to make
certain you can we
we can hit actually there i say our net
that target amongst other things
can i just make a correction on this
page with the cab
refurb we've currently got in for that
project to be completed in 2023 that's
an
error it should be 2025.
so we'll make that correction thank you
so the purpose of this program is to
demonstrate just the challenge in terms
of the pmo
delivering yeah the variety of projects
at various different stages
some of these projects you will see will
be in design while other projects will
be in construction so
it is important to note that not
everything will be in construction
and there's a mix of vertical and
horizontal construction
in there as well so
um look is there anything you can tell
us about just just the actual
development of the pmo
um uh it all is anything relevant we
should hear at this point
because obviously it's the engine
through which you're driving this
control
i'm happy to speak to that um so what
we've done at the moment is we've
developed up what a structure looks like
for the project management office both
in terms of a team
as well as in terms of how we move
through the various stages of the
project from a project control group
through to our steering control group
through to to governance through the
risk and assurance committee
uh the internal team heading up the
project
management office we've decided to keep
to a smaller team
that allows us to supplement the team
with external project management
resources
as well and we've already we're in the
process
of reviewing bids from the external
market for that external support
what that mix of internal and external
resource
allows us to do is to a get up and
running a lot quicker than we would have
been able to
otherwise because we're not trying to
staff a big entity internally
but it also allows us to
gear up and down our resource levels as
we move through various different stages
of the projects as we will have
some areas where we need greater levels
of resource and then we'll drop those
resource levels down
and come back up as we move into other
stages
so essentially what we'll be doing is
partnering with key strategic
partners in the project management space
and the quantity
banking space to move through this
program
with us and we'll be in a position to
advise of those strategic partners in
the coming couple of weeks
like you said with that in terms of you
get your professional notice in
your achievements you've got your
professional services panel up and
running as well too
so you're starting to get some of those
core entry points for these projects in
place
yes and as much as you know we are
talking about tight timelines
there's also been quite a lot of
achievement in terms of
getting contracts up and running um as
we all know we're
a public entity we're not a private
entity so we've got a few extra hoops we
need to jump through in terms of making
sure that we follow
appropriate procurement processes on
these projects
the fact that for the streetscapes for
example
we've already got project management
managers in place quantity surveyors in
place our design
lead in place and we've been out to
market and shortlisted down to our
two main construction contractors of
which we will move through a tender
process with them
um things like that are real positives
for us so
so far we're keeping to the extremely
tight timelines that we've set ourselves
but we we don't have any room for any
mistakes within our program i hear your
point so that just gets us into the
right hand side of the diagram we'll get
back up one page
and i was particularly interested in the
the contractor market and the stress on
resources this is if i can
take the committee's time just as a
constant theme around my other
engagement sales fee around the country
that we are all assuming
and are even seeing some type into the
market what's our approach to
to warning the market sensitizing the
market to our needs going forward
so we're doing a couple of things in
that respect
one is partly leveraging off the
relationships
that that i bring in the team brings in
terms of making sure that contractors
are
are aware of our program having meetings
with them for the streetscapes projects
for
example there was was phone calls and
meetings with key contractors
um that we thought that we could draw in
to come and bid our projects
we are now that we have um those
shortlisted contractors for streetscapes
we're probably
less nervous about the horizontal
infrastructure
resourcing and our nervousness really
moves into that vertical
infrastructure space we have a piece of
work that we are doing
around what is the capacity of that
market over the next
five years both in terms of what
invercargill has
in the pipeline um obviously the
buildings that are underway
the tower that will be going in the
bunnings that will be going in
we're going to be competing with the
private sector through that next
five-year period so what does
invercargill's program look like what
does our program look like
where are we going to get those key
constraints and
frankly watch what contractors are
planning to be here
over that time and what do we need to do
to work with those who perhaps weren't
planning to be here to give them
visibility
we also want to make sure that we get
our programs we're doing some work
around getting our program on the
national infrastructure pipeline
um so we've noticed that there's been
you know
national entries in magazines talking
about the
the construction boom that's happening
in invercargill
you'd have thought it a few years ago um
see the cranes there
at this stage though what invercargill
city council has on its program isn't
showing up
as part of that invercargill
construction boom so we need to make
sure that we get our
stuff front and center there so that
those firms that are thinking about
potentially making that move down here
um get that full picture of what works
available
great thank you for that that's that's
very encouraging if i can say that from
my perspective aaron and tess
the the change here that i've seen and
again and
similar to michael's paper good
transparency as to where we're at so i
like i congratulate you
can i move to the recommendation please
which is that we receive
the report is somebody prepared to move
that
thank you darren thank you rangi i'll
put the motion um all those in favor
please say aye
those against it's carrie thank you guys
that's
tremendous i would like us um to then
move
to oh um urgent business i haven't been
informed of urgent business do members
need to raise anything that i should be
aware of
you don't can i just move then please to
the
motion to move into public excluded
for the reasons that are outlined in
your papers i'll move from the chair
that we move into public excluded could
i have a second to please
thank you nobby all those in favor
please say aye
those against it's carrie can i suggest
um
uh look uh it's ten o'clock i have to be
finished by eleven can we have a five
minute break while
arrangements are made too